they're clearing out this lab and in the
cupboards they found some old equipment
invented by me and I got so excited I
just want to try it out again and it was
designed especially for performing
experiment in the large lecture theatre
with smelly gases when there's no fume
hood to extract the smell and where you
don't want the audience to run out the
reaction angered show you is the
reaction of sulfur dioxide so2 with
hydrogen sulfide h2s hydrogen sulfide is
the gas that smells like rotten eggs and
so2 is also a very acid gas and if you
smell it it is quite unpleasant and here
we've got them both dissolved in water
if you were trying to do this as a
conventional reaction you'd use it
ordinary glassware because the fume
cupboard would take away the smell so
this is my special equipment here there
are two conventional measuring cylinders
which of the glass blowers have put on
one of them a ground glass female joint
and the other one a ground glass male
joint so the idea is this one here has
the hydrogen sulfite nasty and the other
one
has the sulfur dioxide and both of them
are solutions of these gases so now what
we're going to do is quite quickly so
the smell doesn't get out is to pull off
the two stoppers and join them together
so you've seen now they're sealed again
and then you can rotate this one round
so that one liquid runs into the other
and now watch this bottom liquid as it
goes in and you can see there it has
gone a bit yellow and what is happening
is that we have a reaction in which the
hydrogen from one molecule reacts with
the oxygen of the other to make water
and to make sulphur and here the color
is very finely divided sulfur solid
sulfur which doesn't dissolve in water
now you can see first of all this
demonstrates why you don't use sulfur as
yellow paint because it doesn't have a
very bright color but for those of you
who are clean
chemistry nerds like me this is the only
reaction or one of the very few
reactions where so2 acts as an oxidizing
agent so2 is oxidizing h2s usually we
always learn so2 is a reducing agent so
next time if you're at school or college
and the teacher say so2 is a reducing
agent say to them are what about h2s now
the other thing you can see which is
interesting is that although I poured
all the solution into here
that you've got Sun sulfur forming on
the walls here because the h2s gas is
going back this way at the same time as
the solution of so2 is going that way so
the whole thing ends up pretty messy but
the great thing is and Brady can confirm
this to you you can't smell anything so
it's a really good way of doing the
experiment with smelly gases so nobody
smells anything go and make some
yourself the problem of this is a
lecture demonstration is it takes a bit
of time for the sulfur to get to its
maximum color so the audience is a bit
bored by then and you have to go on to
the next thing but with video we can do
the waiting for you at Alabama football
match and now playing a National Anthem
they were showing like a fighter jet on
the screen on the TV screen so we're
singing the national anthem looking at a
fully laden missile carrying fighter jet